المال الراتب الثروه تمثل بدورها الطموح
والاستمراريه والتقدم نحو مستقبل
الاقتصادي افضل للافراد والمجتمعات
فالتكيف مع التقلبات الاقتصاديه الحاده
التي يشهدها العلم قد يستغرق شهورا
بالنسبه للموظفين وبالنسبه لرواد الاعمال
الصغيره يمكن ان تبدا الاشهر الى سنوات
الناشئه في الولايات المتحده كندا انخفض
بنسبه 50% على اساسن سنوي استثمر في نفسك
نصيحه بسيطه تبدو رقيقه من كثره تكرارها
مع ذلك يبدو انها مفتاح النجاح ولا بديل
لها خصوصا في الوقت الحالي الملياردير
والمستثمر الامريكي يقول ان التعلم كيف
تكتب وكيف تتحدث يمكن ان يجعلنا اكثر قيمه
وفاء بنسبه 50% اما نحن عليه الان في 2023
اداره الاعمال قد تكون مهمه شاقه لكن مع
فريق قوي ومدرب يمكن اعتماد عليه قادر على
التعامل بواقعيه مع المتغيرات ربما تكون
الامور اسهل نسبيا
يوجد اكثر من 2000 ملياردير حول العالم
حتى ديسمبر 2022 بحسب مجله فورس جميعهم
يتبنون مفاهيم وشعارات محدده يعتقدون انها
السبب في نجاحهم وتحقيقهم للثروات واليكم
اقتباسات بعض اشهرهم من اشهر اقوال بيل
جيتس مؤسس مايكروسوفت التي تتجاوز ثروته
المئه مليار دولار اذا ولدت فقيرا فهذا
ليس خطا لكن اذا مت فقيرا فهذا خطا قولوا
اخر من مارك زوكربيرج مؤسس فيسبوك ومالك
امبراطوريه متى يقول الخطر الاكبر هو عدم
المخاطره وفي عالم يتغير بسرعه كبيره
الاستراتيجيه الوحيده المضمونه للفشل هي
عدم المخاطره ورنه اشهر مستثمر امريكي
يقول اذا لم تجد طريقه لك المال اثناء
النوم فستعمل حتى تموت اخيرا نادر نرد
ارنوت رجل الاعمال الفرنسيه الذي انتزع
لقب اغنى رجل في العالم من ايلول نصب
مؤخرا يقول المال هو مجرد نتيجه لا تقلق
كثيرا بشان الربح اذا قمت بعملك بشكل جيد
فستجني الربح
[موسيقى]